[Music]
every day in europe
thousands of young people entering the
labor market are faced with a harsh
reality
more often than not they are forced to
accept unfair and unpaid internships
traineeships and precarious work this
common practice is depriving
young europeans of their dignity and of
any possibility for economic
independence
with another crisis looming the
situation is likely to get even worse
more than half of young trainees in
europe haven't been paid during their
traineeships
in january youth unemployment was at
14.9 percent
in august 2020 it hit
17.6 percent and this is expected to
double
in the next few months one in six young
people
has stopped working since the start of
the pandemic
hi my name is mariela and i'm from
austria i'm 26 years old
as many other young europeans i have
done an unpaid internship after i
finished my studies at university
because too often many companies and
organizations
don't pay attorneys any salary and they
don't grant them any workers rights
and i think this is just unfair they
argue that we are not experienced enough
but inexperienced doesn't mean
disposable
i think that this is a european problem
which needs to be tackled at an eu level
therefore we demand an answer from the
eu institutions
way too often young people are offered
unfed internships with no educational
value whatsoever
they are treated as cheap workforce well
often in fact as free workforce
the reform of the youth guarantee this
important program of the union offers us
the opportunity to change things for the
better
but we demand more now it's high time to
put young people's rights on top of the
eu agenda
we demand a legal framework banning
unpaid internships and traineeships all
over the eu
go ask a young person reputation is not
remuneration
and experience does not pay your bills
so
pay your interns